Let's shrink an elephant to the size of a mouse and in large amounts and make it
the size of an elephant because this is our video and we want to see what
happens first hour.
Now tiny elephant stumbles around and then drops dead.
Tiny elephant buddy is very cold,
frozen to death in minutes.
Our giant mouse looks very uncomfortable for a moment and then it explodes
leaving hot mouse insides everywhere.
Why?
Because of size.
We are optimized to function precisely for the science we are and would die
horribly in any other environment,
but why exactly?
Why does our mouse explode and can we do this to our elephant too if we try hard
life on this planet is based on cells.
Cells do vary in size,
but they're pretty similar in their dimensions across all species.
A blue whale doesn't have bigger sales than a hummingbird,
just a lot more often sells have to do a lot of stuff to stay alive and they
need energy to be able to do so.
To get this energy,
animal cells convert food and oxygen into usable chemical energy.
This happens in our Mitochondria,
the powerhouse of the cell.
They're like little call engines that spit out tiny ATP batteries,
which the cell can use for almost everything it needs to do.
Just like an engine.
Mitochondria get ready hot while working in human skin cells.
They reach a scorching 50 degrees Celsius and some of ourselves have up to 2000
Mitochondria which are radiating that heat and to the south.
So being alive generates a lot of heat.
The more cells you have,
the more heat your body generates.
In total,
if our bodies didn't find ways of losing this heat,
we would be cooked from the inside and die.
But this is a problem for bigger animals because of the way he bought his
change.
His living being scaled up.
Animals have three properties here that are important that length,
their outsides or skin and their insights like organs,
bones and hopes and dreams.
The thing that's hard to wrap your head around is that when things grow,
their insides grow faster than their outsides.
Imagine a fleshy cube.
If you double the length of its sides,
it's surface and volume do not double.
In fact,
the surface is now four times the original size and the volume of the cube eight
times the original size,
which is called the square cube law and has been annoying nature for billions of
years.
So why is this a problem for big animals?
Because heat can only leave an object via its surface.
So if we make our mouse the size of an elephant or 60 times longer,
it has 3,600 times more surface from which to lose heat.
But it has 216,000 times more volume filled with trillions and trillions of new
hot mitochondria that produce more heat,
a lot more insights,
not that much more skin.
Our mouse is very dead,
very fast,
barn to big things like elephants exist.
So how do they deal with the heat?
For one,
they evolved ways to get rid of energy more easily.
Like huge flat is that have a lot of surface where heat can escape,
but that's not enough.
Nature's solution is actually very elegant.
Elephant cells are much,
much slower than myself.
The bigger an animal is,
the less active it's cells.
Or if we classify animals by their metabolic rates and compare that to their
overall mass.
It's clearly visible.
It's not 100% accurate,
but it is a good rule of thumb.
Elephants are huge meat sacks filled with trillions and trillions of little coal
ovens,
so they keep the oven's just active enough to keep the running and never at full
power.
Their whole metabolism is slow.
Things move at a nice chill pace.
Small animals need to go the exact opposite way.
If you're small,
you have a lot of surface area compared to not a lot of volume.
You don't have a lot of cell ovens and lose the heat.
They produce very fast,
so very tiny mammals came up with a very extreme solution.
Meet the a trust can true the smallest mammal on earth.
The mold like thing that's more closely related to hedgehogs than to mice.
With the body length of four centimeters,
it only weighs about 1.8 grams as much as it Pedro Cape.
It's a tiny,
ridiculous being.
It would basically cool off immediately so it's cells run on overdrive to stay
warm.
It's tiny.
Ovens are filled at maximum capacity.
It's hard to be,
it's up to 1200 times a minute and it brings up to 800 times a minute.
This creates an extreme need for energy,
so the shrew has to eat constantly after only four hours without food.
It starves to death.
And while an African elephant consumes around 4% of its body weight in food each
day,
our shrew needs 200% of its body weight in food a day just to survive.
Imagine having to eat 2000 big Max a day,
more than one a minute fun for awhile,
but then not so much so a cubic centimeter of shrew needs at 40 times more food
than a cubic centimeter of elephant.
If an elephant cells certainly become as active as the cells of a shrew,
a crazy amount of heat would be generated.
All the liquids and the elephant would suddenly start boiling and then it would
explode in an impressive explosion of steaming hot burning and often parts in
reality,
before an explosion occurred,
the proteins making up house sellers would probably beat natures and stop
producing heat,
but a meet exposion as much more fun than melting and elephant into a massive
hot glue.
Regardless,
the scaling of the speed of metabolism happens everywhere.
Even in places we don't expect,
like pregnant women,
a baby in the womb of his mother behaves as if it were a part of her itselves
have about the same metabolic rate,
the same speed of life as it's mother's organs.
It is truly a part of a bigger whole rather than an individual until it's not
anymore.
The very moment a baby is born,
a switches,
Flint and audits internal processes speed up rapidly,
36 hours after birth.
The baby's cells have the same activity rate as a mammal.
It's size.
They've is literally transition from being an organ to being an individual in
mere hours.
But there's one thing where big and small things are very similar.
Heartbeat.
Mammals tend to have a similar amount of heartbeats over their lifetime,
typically around 1 billion,
so while the shrew and elephant are very different,
they share a similar number of heartbeats over the course of their lives.
Their speed of life is the opposite and somehow still the same and for a video
in which we made elephants explode for no good reason,
this is the most romantic ending we could come up with.
Speaking of romance and love,
one of the questions we get asked most often is how we make animated videos.
The short answer is with Adobe after effects and years of training,
but rather than just points you to our favorite online tutorial service,
we decided to make a skill Schatz tutorial expanding how we made a scene from
one of our videos.
If you aren't already familiar with this,
skillshare is an online learning community with more than 18,000 classes and
things like writing animation and video editing.
Their premium membership gives you unlimited access to high quality classes from
professionals working in their fields so you can improve your skills,
unlock new opportunities,
and did work that you'd really enjoy.
It's also extremely affordable.
The annual subscription is less than $10 a month,
but because we appreciate you,
we've arranged for the first 1000 people to get their first two months
absolutely free.
If you want to learn how we animate our stuff,
this is the way to go,
okay.
This concludes cords cause aren't for 12,017 happy holidays.
Everybody.